the drive to tank positions on the
Eastern Front is often along muddy
isolated roads
hidden in the forest under wet Autumn
Leaves we find Ukrainian Soldiers with
the fifth assault tank regiment
tanks here have been vital in preventing
a Russian Advance as Ukrainian troops
continue a counter-offensive that has
recently retaken thousands of square
kilometers from Russian forces
the forests will offer less cover from
Russian drones and airstrikes in the
coming weeks and months heavy machine
gun fire Echoes through the trees
of the final preparations the signal to
move is given
[Music]
the near 40 year old t-72 tank moves out
from under the trees
it's a five minute drive to its firing
position exposing the crew to Russia
attack
we follow it to a nearby field and
within a minute The Telltale winding
sounds signal it will fire in seconds
a minute later a second blast
so the tank has moved into its operating
position
we understand that they are firing at
Russian positions about three kilometers
from here the tanks operating here are
part of a wider counter-offensive in the
East that has seen great success in
recent weeks
[Music]
time now is of the essence move back
into cover before Russian forces locate
the firing position and reply
this tank a soldier tells us is one of
around a hundred that Russian soldiers
abandoned in the past month when they
fled the ongoing Ukrainian Army Advance
suddenly the sound of a jet fighter
approaching
we struggle to see it through the leaves
above as it screams overhead
Alexander says he has a wife and child
waiting for him when the war is over
but he doesn't know when that will be
our role as a tank regiment is very
important because we are preventing
Russian forces from moving forward as
our troops advance
Nicola tells me he's not worried about
the possibility of a push by thousands
of new Russian conscripts as part of
Russian President Vladimir Putin's
so-called partial mobilization
don't matter how many men they they
bring here is that don't matter for us
our machine guns can shoot what hundred
thousand rounds a minute if you shoot 5
or 50 I don't think our machine Gunners
will be tired
Ukrainian military says it's winning
back territory in the East bit by bit
day by day
so far evidence on the battlefield at
least suggests moscow's military
response is yet to come
Charles Strafford Al Jazeera eastern
Ukraine